[Musique]
lui c'est mon père
son cas je préférais c'est le langage
corporel
mais il n'ya pas que mon père à voir son
langage bien à lui ya le langage des
preuves continuent de descendre à pau se
retrouvera du pétrole et un langage à
moi bon ça c'est un faux bulletin hockey
dans ce jeu baratin nito
je préfère un 16 cantons sur neuf
premiers de la classe tu es ma fierté
un jour tu seras président ça me fait
marrer avec ton page c'est parce que tu
vas pas en face de toi je viens voir à
la réunion parents-profs s'il fait super
que ça c'est quand l'art dit ignorer les
convocations
cette fois çi témoin il faut une sacrée
bonne idée
j'ai envoyé mon vrai père rencontre est
née au profit oil candidats aux profs
cyclistes à ça vient tranquille très
bonne et très très bons élèves voilà
pourquoi james gray père laissez moi
deviner il sans laurent nous a bouclé
l'épreuve
il faut rien redoublement à la rigueur
voire deux opère je vais m'en occuper
c'est mon adresse rendez vous à 14
heures et si je veux pas voir ça avec
ton père enfin le vrai
si le passé en seconde tu as deux mois
pour redresser la barre cette fois ci on
jouait la régulière amour et ta parole
je compte pas il va dire quoi quand tu
va redoubler je vais le tcd et le
ressuscité une blonde
abou big mac os mac chicane forme sunday
chuck baker hughes est